[Music]
recognize these faces well how about
these two yeah they're the same people
britney spears's sons jaden james and
sean preston looking all grown up at 15
and 16. brittany and the boy's dad kevin
federline have largely kept them out of
the spotlight i can't imagine how it
feels to be a teenager having to go to
high school
who knows how many people ask them about
it fans got a rare glimpse of the boys
thanks to a new interview kevin filmed
for the uk's itv the network's daphne
barack got an inside look at kevin's
life with his wife victoria we also see
the boys hanging around the house and
loving on their sisters jordan k and
payton marie in another photo the family
looks happy as they dine out i mean
we're doing this for our children but
this interview isn't all family fun it's
also stirring controversy me and britt
are good it's it's you know everybody
knows i've had a tough road but um
i'm i'm happy where we're at yeah but
fast forward to 2022 things look a
little different for the x's the former
backup dancer makes some unexpected
allegations involving his and brits boys
like the status of their current
relationship with brittany the boys have
decided that
you know
they they're they're not seeing her
right now
he also says the kids opted not to go to
her wedding with sam eskari citing her
suggestive instagram posts as a factor
in their decision they
started sending me
videos and certain things that they were
like look i'm telling you that this is
happening
for now kevin isn't revealing what their
sons saw or sent but when k-fed's quotes
first got out over the weekend britt
wasn't having it in a lengthy message
shared to instagram she wrote it saddens
me to hear that my ex-husband has
decided to discuss the relationship
between me and my children they're
really confused with mommy the star and
and mommy you know so it's really
interesting to see they're like is that
britney spears or is that you mommy i'm
like it's the same person
[Laughter]
it's really sweet
and those claims about her risque social
media posts well the pop icon offered as
we all know raising teenage boys is
never easy for anyone do you get any
like cool points for being britney
spears like as mom i guess sometimes i
don't i'm not sure
and yeah brits hubby had her back it's
the happiest time of our lives and we're
just enjoying it in the story of his own
sam wrote there is no validity to his
statement regarding the kids distancing
themselves and it is irresponsible to
make that statement publicly and in
another now deleted message he said
their sons will eventually realize their
mother's choices are harmless at an
expression of newly found freedom
[Music]